la amniocentesis es un procedimiento que
les permite a los médicos detectar o
descartar problemas en la salud de los
bebés mucho antes de su nacimiento en el
útero el bebé está rodeado del líquido
amniótico que proporciona protección y
alimento
las células del bebé se encuentran
flotando en el líquido lo que les
proporciona a los médicos material
genético para su evaluación en la
amniocentesis el médico tomará una
muestra del líquido para evaluar
trastornos genéticos específicos y
defectos de nacimiento la amniocentesis
por lo general se hace en el segundo
trimestre de embarazo entre la semana 15
y 18 generalmente se les ofrece a las
mujeres con determinados factores de
riesgo mujeres de 35 años de edad o
mayores lo que aumenta el riesgo de
trastornos cromosomáticos como el
síndrome de dawn un embarazo o niño
anterior con algún defecto de nacimiento
análisis de sangre o ultrasonido que
sugiere un defecto de nacimiento como
síndrome de down o defectos del tubo
neural o un antecedente familiar de
trastornos genéticos como fibrosis
cística la amniocentesis también puede
ser realizada en el tercer trimestre por
las siguientes razones para determinar
si debiera ser necesario un parto
prematuro cuando los pulmones del bebé
están lo suficientemente maduros para
diagnosticar una infección uterina o
para controlar la anemia en un bebé con
compatibilidad r
para comenzar el procedimiento el médico
usará ultrasonido para crear una imagen
del feto y estructuras cercanas en la
pantalla de una computadora mientras
mira la imagen el médico puede elegir un
lugar seguro para insertar la aguja el
médico puede administrarle una inyección
de anestesia local para adormecer la
superficie del abdomen en donde se va a
insertar la aguja de la amniocentesis
el médico mirará cuidadosamente el
monitor ultrasonido para evitar el
contacto con la placenta o el bebé luego
introducirá la delgada aguja a través de
la pared abdominal en el útero y en el
saco amniótico
extraerá una pequeña muestra del líquido
amniótico
quitará la aguja y cubrirá el sitio con
una venda su cuerpo fabricará el líquido
adicional para reemplazar el que se
extrajo
el médico seguirá observando el
ultrasonido para verificar que los
latidos del corazón del feto sean
normales y que el bebé tolero bien el
procedimiento es posible que sienta
leves ganas de defecar o presión en el
abdomen inferior durante aproximadamente
24 horas después del procedimiento se le
aconsejará a evitar el estrés físico
como ejercicio enérgico alzamientos
quedarse de pie durante un tiempo
prolongado y actividad sexual